hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play
I'm need you a machine for pigs ok we
just got out of the water part and we're
in one of the lowermost levels in this
place which means that we got to do
something ok there's another valve over
here that I can't turn ok so there's
something that wait a minute
is that actually something this looks
like a gear is there something I'm
supposed to put in here
aha there we go well that was easy
enough where's the last one there's got
to be another over here I saw another
spoke ok so wait a minute hi hi you
can't keep me in here I'm a free man
there's something like that I don't know
ok so there's another spoke around here
somewhere that I gotta find should be
simple enough I mean it's not exactly a
big rum hello hello hello
oh whoops whoops
no one saw anything no one saw me
totally missed that right in front of my
face ok and sure all wheels are in place
oh I already know that oh don't think I
don't know click link ok can I go
through here now that did something some
happened something big so I'm turning on
all the machinery again because someone
sabotaged it alright so I think that's
where I came from
um do I need to go back I'm not entirely
sure and whoa what that what that say
see the flood is drained I have
prevailed The Saboteur is beatin my
heart pounds with excitement even as my
head spins and shudders and fevers and
dissipation how this machine now throbs
about me sensing its rebirth is imminent
the final descent beckons me to enter as
Lily once lay on our wedding bed and
summoned me into manhood that whole
excerpt was way more sexual than it
needed to be I'm just gonna say that
right now ok what is over here I don't
think I've been here before
oh good there's the piles of cages again
and trail of blood leads down here and
whoop hey
I was slippery what the hell happened
why am i down here this red light oh no
does the trash compactor from Star Wars
I've seen this before if there's a
monster tentacle monsters gonna come up
I'm holding an object Pro ah I got to
pick up this giant piece of [ __ ] and
just here we go
well what was the point of that was the
point of that just just make me slide in
there did something push me in you son
of a [ __ ] okay anyway oh don't ever go
go you don't be shaking don't be chicken
hanging okay so I need to go back now
that I've drained the water that's
awfully loud but whatever okay that's
just water dripping okay so now the
lower level should be yeah okay oh wow
wow oh my face
okay so there's steam blocking me from
going that way and I can't get back out
this way aha the ladder good good
another ladder that's not gonna fall
into the abyss or a trash compactor
hi buddy
how you doing can you do again did your
girl
gotta here I don't like you I don't like
you very much I'm up never me and the
water monster have never had a quite an
agreement oh good another
decontamination chamber because I'm
covered in excrement excrement close
that door
turn this dumb [ __ ] on ding maybe this
just pressurizes this room I mean it can
hardly get off the cake layers of crap
on my coat I like the alliteration there
so now I must continue onward venture
forth in my quest to seek the holy grail
my favorite color is blue
no yellow okay is there something in
here got a lot quieter oh okay end of
the level the children dancing he
obsessively scans the newspapers and
periodicals for new inventions they are
the architecture to elevate ever late us
all he proclaims Edwin and Enoch display
on unaware okay whatever you say buddy I
know you're crazy psycho bonkers so what
do we have here huh seems like we've
reached another layer made of wood and
brick and hopefully out of the sewers
still stinks like rotten meat curled
into my bunk all sick and sweat ridden
they clean my room around me but I can
only hear the voice from within the
gentlest of stones it sings to me and I
dream of a great machine we will build a
new world from the ruins of the old we
will plant flowers in the rotten ribcage
and let them grow to hold the sky from
falling I remember how it whispered to
me as we're old sick and heaving and I
remember when we pulled into Southampton
and we both wept for it was every bit as
much a desecration as had been sung to
me and then we came to London and I said
it upon the mantelpiece and went into
the house and gathered the servants and
said Enric rafting them and then I went
into the garden and buried those tiny
shattered skulls under the weeping
bulges of the rhododendrons and guessing
when the children died or you're talking
about Norb I'm not entirely sure but
someone pointed out in the comments that
this this stone egg they might have
found might actually be an orb and I
didn't think of that before
stop no unauthorized person Jaya [ __ ]
you okay going continuing hey wait a
minute no this is dead end that's why
okay
just seems to be a series of tubes
is that the orb talking to me what else
would I set on the mantelpiece okay what
does that mean what are you talking
about buddy am I the saboteur am i the
saboteur in my fevered
well
okay that is a big-ass machine over
there what does it do what does it do I
want to know what it do what do we do
Christ what is this place uh the heart
of the machine I'm just guessing hang on
there's a door over here let me check it
before I go forward towards the machine
rod the rods oh boy I guess you play
with rods again I'm so excited
can't wait to handle those rods okay
click oh really really I gotta
manipulate each little one of these
click click click like ooh oh well
that's not a good sound and they feel no
pain the process is completely humane is
it you a professor then we judge the
acceptable level of suffering by the
human condition uh ask the beggar
professor asked the often ask the poor
ask the starving professor the weak the
sick the filthy ask them to define your
humane oh that one doesn't like that
what did my thing say the bastard is
been here too this is the epicenter of
his meddlings this is where it began and
this is where it will end I will seek
the source of this obstruction and then
I will run to this sabotage impotent
once and for all
I have a feeling your notes are getting
a bit more sexualized click Luke hey
blue Hembree about come on ok so there's
some sort of obstruction down below I
wonder how awesome it'll be I wonder if
it'll be totally amazing and I'm not
going down a dark corridor that I don't
like hello somebody here
yeah going into dark tunnels it's my
baby it's my fav II spice baby ever see
danger compound X highly corrosive
highly flammable highly toxic well maybe
I shouldn't take my flickering faulting
Lantern here okay
kachunk aha that was the thing what was
that oh it's just a light what is that
am I able to go over there and know okay
so there's something over there wonder
if I could get there if I lift it up
some of the rods
I know it's highly toxic oh no it's not
huh
confusing I'm guessing that clicking
might be a Geiger counter so I might
want it you know get out of here just
saying okay that wasn't much of an
obstruction I have to say that was
actually quite tame if I do say so
myself something gonna jump out of me
okay
nothing happened that's kind of actually
weird a little bit sir nothing happened
but junk yay I'm so amazing in all duda
ding dong what did that do what did that
do why why was that a thing why did I
even need to do that I guess to make the
rods work for some reason maybe that's
some sort of a nuclear reactor now to
find the ignition control since start
the machine once more elated I stride
forth upon these catwalks I am coming my
darling I have almost saved you if you
say so man if you say so
not me
all right maybe this is some sort of
metaphor for the machine being my
children
that's one who did that Oh lights okay
what's going on what's going on here now
madness set them free set them somehow I
don't think I should
something tells me this might be a bad
idea but here we go anyway
Hey Oh
I built a Reaper apparently I breathe
again I rise I will rise to bleach the
sky and steal the water I will spin the
world wheel and set the future upon the
path to redemption where are my children
you promised me my children my time is
come
okay boys
sorry
oopss
oh oh oh they ripped their own hearts
out that's pretty horrific why'd they do
that mandus Saboteur returning from
Mexico I was struck again by London's
filth the squalor the miasma the rot we
should cut free the dead flesh allow
this wound to heal anew whatever you say
man I think you got a psycho crazy
bonkers oh okay
I'm still alive gone but only slightly
and emerging I raised my head to an
uncaring Sun and I cursed this world of
pain and despair uh-huh
this civilization built on the rickety
bones of the unfortunate on the greed
and swell of Mammon and Empire huh
cradling a stone egg in my jacket I
kissed my children farewell and I
crawled my way home right but uh what
about that big-ass machine that you're
building you're kind of gonna do the
thing who I kids is going hey buddies
after I get out of here
but look it's a piggy piggy mask can a
man construct himself anew can a man on
realizing who he is on what he has
become tear himself apart down to the
bricks and begin anew are our souls just
this tiny cog wheels and clockwork and
intricate machines to serve a function
that upon reflection we might set to a
new task can a man defined by his
actions defined by that which he is now
found a pourraient set to sabotaging his
body
there's machine until those children of
his soul turn in new motion and he may
awake to a new son a new year a new
century with hope in his heart as I
reach my hands to the exposed wires I
ask myself this is Redemption possible
for such a creature as I and if not then
surely better to die amongst my
creations than to continue live as a
monster
who if you say so man if you say so see
I cannot pick these masks up they've
been everywhere what is it all mean tall
a machine for pigs can't get my journal
I'm climbing pressure regulation this is
where I overload so it is done The
Saboteur was me and the voice on the
telephone was him but what of us how do
we connect surely I cannot be
responsible for all I see about me I
can't remember
I cannot remember all I can grasp is a
moment when the world split into two
pieces and the innards of humanity fell
from an orifice torna gape into my open
bifurcated heart bifurcated mean split
into two case he didn't know that okay
where are my um dead yeah cuz they be
dead children really are the most
wonderful useful creatures the
unfortunates from the orphanage approved
indispensable in cleaning the largest
empires steam it appears that matter
from the slaughtering process may indeed
vaporize its source but drifts like dust
through the air and laughter's in the
pipes causing them to foul periodically
we shut the pressure down and send one
of our Pixies into the Pyke's to scrub
in debris with the reconstituted fat
away armed with just a shortened broom
our little explorers venture into the
dark of course we can only keep pressure
down for a short period so they must be
fast or they risk being trapped and
boiled by the superheated vapors when
they rush back into the systems then we
what was sending their comrades in after
him to scrape free the cooling mess the
survivors tell me you can reach all
manner of places within the complex
through the pipes I smile tell them I am
so proud and then feed them to the pigs
what the hell man cease you're like some
sort of crazy man suck on that did the
brown yeah what now [ __ ] yeah yeah
right a flute
oh what's that pipes getting a little
stopped up being a little constipated or
a pressure building allow you to
sabotage yes okay where do I go oh I go
back okay there go there must be away
there must be away through to my
children you will not stop me oh that's
not a good sound what is that that's a
teddy bear will it hurt a cleansing fire
always burns little mandersohn but it
purifies and it makes a new dirt
did it hurt to carve out the fevered
flesh did it hurt to cut free the
gangrenous foot ask instead this
we save them when did I say that that is
not me that is not me uh I think you
might have lost your memory a bit there
mandus there's more people okay
oh boy okay time for sleep now go to
sleep little piggy oh hi
how's it going buddy did you leave me a
note love letter
okay there's a spoon of Medicine I says
and it's a silver spoon what you did get
born holding ever so painfully for mummy
dear but grasp so hard it was in a
little screaming red fist later you use
your spoon to dig a hole in the garden
and get all the way to Mexico and then
you did eat worms with your spoon on the
way to stay fat this spoon with the same
you gave your twins then you used it to
dig a hole to their clockwork souls and
you ate up their hearts like soup on the
way to keep you fat fat little Mole
where will you dig next I asks you and
your little silver spoon made from the
silver spine of your children and
wrapped in the hair of your dearly
departed dear sweet Jesus my darling
lilibeth what am i become so are these
notes from myself ok anyway that's all
the time after this part who is getting
I don't even know what's going on this
this story is getting incredibly complex
so anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
Wow
supposed to happen
let me get away
good God
the denim
Oh